[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
JILLY GAGNON: All right.
So yeah.
Not the most technologically
advanced persons.
When I manage to mess up
the four-button clicker,
you've been warned.
So I'm Jilly.
MIKE MACDONALD: And I'm Mike.
JILLY GAGNON: And this is
"Choose Your Own Misery:
The Google Talk."
We like colons.
They make things seem
much more official.
So one of the things
we sort of thought
we would talk about
today-- writing a book,
it's sort of a solo
situation most of the time.
And one of the things that's
kind of interesting about us
is that writing as a team.
Not very many people do that.
And we've been writing comedy
as a team for like, four years?
MIKE MACDONALD: Yeah.
I think it has been that long.
I got my start off at "The
Onion," America's funnest news
source.
I was an editorial intern.
And I wrote for
them for a few years
before I decided
that I want to write
my own try at doing this,
but doing a Canadian version.
I'm in fact from
Toronto, Canada.
JILLY GAGNON: [INAUDIBLE]
MIKE MACDONALD:
You're from Toronto?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MIKE MACDONALD: OK, cool.
So what I did was the
first thing I had to do
is incorporate a company, and
then recruit some writers.
I found Jilly's
work on a website
called "McSweeney's
Internet Tendencies."
And she wrote some
extremely funny stuff.
So I reached out to her
with an email, and I said,
would you like to write for us?
And luckily, she obliged.
JILLY GAGNON: Yes.
I saw he sent an email.
I was about to get on a plane
and it was the magic words
at the very end.
This was 2011.
It was back in my writing
for exposure days.
And it was the magic words,
"we pay our writers."
And I was like, I don't
know who this person is.
I don't know what
satire news is.
Never heard of you.
But I'm so there.
So I signed on.
And we started doing
a satire news site.
And perhaps because I have
particularly apparent OCD,
I was one of the early
enthusiastic contributors
to the website.
MIKE MACDONALD: Yeah.
We had a lot of
great writers that
have sort of written for various
platforms in various magazines.
We had thought back in the
day that we could actually
make a go out of it with
just ad impressions alone.
I think the CPM saw
the clicks per 1,000
were somewhere near
$10 or whatever.
And I thought that--
JILLY GAGNON: We
were gonna be rich.
MIKE MACDONALD: That would
be a great source of revenue
for this media empire.
Unfortunately,
some people sort of
fell off as other jobs took
part and other projects came up.
But Jilly and I
really plowed through.
JILLY GAGNON: Yep.
MIKE MACDONALD: And yeah.
We were-- here are
some articles actually
that Jilly wrote for "The Smew."
JILLY GAGNON: Yeah.
So you have to remember
it was a simpler
time when our Donald Trump
was named Michele Bachmann.
And you know, it was
our best efforts here.
Also, Alan Thicke, anybody
who disagrees with me
that he is Canada's
best celebrity,
we're going to have to
throw down, because he is
an absolute favorite of mine.
And we did a whole series
of articles-- well,
I did a whole series of
articles-- and browbeat Mike
into letting me run
them, which where
an increasing obsession
with Alan Thicke.
I believe we sort of
ended that series on her
in the bushes outside the home.
The cops.
You know.
Every week she would
write about Alan.
MIKE MACDONALD: Yeah.
We were having a
party up in Toronto.
And we actually reached
out to Alan Thicke's people
in the hopes that he'd come
and grace us with a few words.
Unfortunately, we
couldn't make that happen.
JILLY GAGNON: We
couldn't swing it.
But you can swing Alan Thicke.
This is a really fun takeaway.
You can hire Alan Thicke to just
hang out with you for a fee.
A reasonably affordable
fee, all things considered.
I mean, "Growing
Pains" was legit.
So.
MIKE MACDONALD: So as the
editor of this publication,
I would often get 10 to
15 different headlines.
Here's some finished
headlines that we did publish.
And I would sift through them.
And I would look
for what I would
think would be sort of the
funniest joke that could
be fleshed out into an article.
Oftentimes one of the
writers were Americans,
so we'd have to sort of just
switch up a few pronouns
or what have you to make it
a lot more Canadian-centric.
JILLY GAGNON: A lot more "yous."
MIKE MACDONALD: I think Julie
got a pretty good education
in Canadian politics by the
time that we were finished.
JILLY GAGNON: And
Canadian spelling,
MIKE MACDONALD: Yeah.
And putting the "you" in color
and stuff like that, of course.
But we wanted to hit on politics
of some evergreen ideas,
as you can see with
"Scientists Weaponize Maternal
Disappointment."
And then we had a bunch
of op eds as well.
JILLY GAGNON: But sort
of one of the things
was really interesting that
you learn really quickly
doing comedy I would say more
than any kind of writing,
it's a cliche to say that
you face a lot of rejection
when you write.
Obviously, you face a lot
of rejection when you write.
But when you write
comedy, there is--
like, no one wants to see
how a hot dog is made.
But if you could see
the kinds of things
that we reject for "The Smew,"
they're out of those 10 or 15
headlines that I would
send in every week,
the other 20 writers would
be sending in every week,
each writer might
get one or two.
And that's us.
We weren't "The Onion."
They might have 100 headlines.
And they would pick one
that they actually write up.
So we sort of learned early
on as a team doing "The Smew"
that one of the
things that you have
to be willing to do in comedy
is let go and have your ego not
be so tied up in every
single joke you make,
because almost
certainly it is not
as funny as you think it is.
It is rarely as funny
as you think it is.
MIKE MACDONALD: Yeah, exactly.
I think we've all
sort of worshipped
at the altar of "is this funny."
And if it's funny, we'll run it.
And if it's not, then we just
put our ego aside and move on
to sort of the next joke.
JILLY GAGNON: So
working on "The Smew,"
it quickly became clear that
myself and one other writer
were more enthusiastic about
the "you got paid for your work"
experience than others.
And over the first couple
of months it was just that.
But at some point,
Mike reached out
and he said, would you
be interested in doing
other things as well?
You're enthusiastic.
You're writing good articles.
He and his co-founder,
Paul Metcalfe,
said, would you guys want
to write something else?
So we did.
Myself and Paul Houseman, who
this book is dedicated to-- you
should ask him about the
frog in a blender joke.
It's terrible.
It's never been funny-- we
started writing other things
in addition to "The Smew."
So that was going on
in the background.
But we started--
These are some really
charming photos of me
in some of the sketches
we wrote as the only girl
in this group of
comedy writers, I
got to sort of sub
in whenever there
was a female-- I don't
even know what I'm
doing in the right-hand side.
I don't know why
I'm wearing that.
But we had lighting.
So it seemed really official.
MIKE MACDONALD: Exactly.
JILLY GAGNON: I
felt really special.
MIKE MACDONALD: Yeah.
We started off with sort of
like a vignette of short videos
that we put up on the website.
And the idea was--
JILLY GAGNON: Not telling
you where those live.
MIKE MACDONALD: Yeah, exactly.
The idea was to make each
video around 30 seconds.
You know, conceive of an
idea, execute it on film,
and put it up on the website.
And there was a lot of fun.
And then I guess from
there we progressed
into writing scripts.
I had a connection with
the Canadian Broadcasting
Corporation wherein I
could pitch some ideas.
So we started to just
toss around ideas,
some from our own, some just
very funny premises for shows.
JILLY GAGNON: Yeah.
MIKE MACDONALD: What
was the first thing
that we came up with?
JILLY GAGNON: I
think the first thing
we came up with it was called
"Walbridge Preparatory."
I think this one was mine.
Which was, it was somewhere
between the children
in "The Shining" and
some deserted island,
but a prep school.
It was weird.
It was a very strange idea
that I thought was comic gold.
Like, everyone was
going to get this.
These weirdo children in
their weirdo prep school.
And you know, they're
kind of murderous.
And understandably, Mike
went in with that one.
And they said, this
isn't very broad.
This is a little specific.
Probably you're not going
to get much of an audience.
So we tried to get more broad.
And I think the closest we got
was probably "Victory Cafe."
MIKE MACDONALD: Yeah.
That was a cafe wherein
a few people had
gone to in the afternoon, and
a zombie apocalypse broke out.
JILLY GAGNON: Like it does.
MIKE MACDONALD: Yeah.
The only refuge within
the city was in this cafe.
But of course, they wanted
to resume normal cafe life.
So they'd often
leave the cafe to go
outside looking
for coffee beans,
come back, and then make
their mochas, what have you.
JILLY GAGNON: Like,
why live in a world
without a really awesome latte.
I think that was the tag
line we came up with.
So their bunker was
this cafe that they
had to defend against
all zombies at all costs.
Also, unsurprisingly,
not broad enough.
Not broad enough comedy there.
So eventually, people sort
of got a little worn out.
We wrote like four or
five different pilots.
We tried to come up
with these scripts.
We tried to come
up with sketches.
I would go up to Toronto.
Paul would go up to Toronto.
We'd try to film them.
But people have real lives.
And working sort
of for free is--
it's hard to keep the
enthusiasm up on that when
you keep getting told "no."
So it sort of tapered
off eventually.
And it winnowed down, I would
say, to Mike and myself.
We sort of-- maybe we were just
completely stubborn or stupid.
But we said we will
continue to do this.
But we did give up first
and get some office jobs.
MIKE MACDONALD: Yeah.
One of the benefits
of "The Smew"
was that it did get me a job at
the sort of largest newspaper
chain in Canada
called Post Media.
Where I got to write a lot
of humor and a lot of comedy
as a columnist.
You can see there working away.
I don't know what
I'm doing there.
Maybe writing about a soccer
game or what have you.
JILLY GAGNON: Yeah.
Watching soccer basically
is what you're doing.
MIKE MACDONALD:
But after writing
within these sort of confines
for a large audience at Post
Media, wherein you couldn't
really say everything
that you wanted to say,
often I would come home
and I'd jump on Skype.
And I would then talk with
Jilly about the next idea
that we wanted to work on.
So we were continuing
to work on scripts.
Lots of times we
were writing you
know, op eds for
zanier publications,
and just editing
it back and forth.
JILLY GAGNON: Contributing
jokes to "The Onion."
MIKE MACDONALD: Yeah.
Writing for "The Onion" as well.
JILLY GAGNON: So we
were in this habit.
We would get together at
least a few times a week
on Skype, because Mike
is based in Toronto.
I'm based here in Boston.
So everything was done
over the internet.
We met over the internet.
The internet is for
real friendships.
And once we had taken
these office jobs,
one of the themes
that quickly emerged
was how ill-suited we were
for these office jobs,
and how unhappy we were in this.
Not because that
office jobs were bad.
They were fine.
They were decent jobs.
But we weren't doing what
was making us passionate.
We weren't going
to work every day
and writing comedy
for eight hours.
We were going and doing somebody
else's work and somebody else's
passion.
And it was draining.
And we are misanthropic people.
And it made us want to write
something that was totally
our own, and perhaps
influenced what
was Mike's idea at the time.
We would throw each
other ideas all the time.
And Mike came in with a few.
I came in with a few.
And the one that stood
out was this idea
of "Choose Your Own Misery:
The Office Adventure."
Which you can sort of
explain your initial--
MIKE MACDONALD: Sure.
I think we were
on Skype chatting.
I had three ideas.
And the first two
were just terrible.
And Jilly was like, eh.
There's no way we're touching
either of these ideas.
And then the third
idea I had was
a book about a guy trying to get
through one day in an office.
But whatever choice he takes,
whatever route he goes down,
he either gets rerouted
back to the beginning,
much in the same way you do in
real life, or you get fired.
Or you get worker's
comp, or something.
You can't win.
You can't win the day.
And then Jilly--
JILLY GAGNON: We thought
we were really happy.
You know, like
this moment, right?
MIKE MACDONALD: Yeah.
Yeah.
Jilly jumped on it.
And she's like, oh,
that's a great idea.
We should totally write this up.
I wasn't terribly
certain about the idea.
So I gave it to her.
I said, you run with this idea.
If you like it,
you should do it.
Which she did coax me into.
JILLY GAGNON: He's
like, it's probably
not-- it's probably nothing.
So you take it.
Sort of like when you're a
kid in elementary school.
And you're like,
this tastes gross.
You try it.
That was how the book started.
MIKE MACDONALD: Yeah.
JILLY GAGNON: This tastes gross.
MIKE MACDONALD: So I guess when
we got started with the book,
I got a very interesting job
offer to go to East Africa
to work for a company called
Journals for Human Rights.
So it was based in Dar
Es Salaam, Tanzania.
We continued to write the book.
But of course, there
was more challenges
that were in the way.
One of them being
just internet access.
I'd have to go to the shop and
get an internet stick and stick
it in.
And I'd be sending
Jilly all these emails.
And it would take
two or three minutes
to load up a single page.
JILLY GAGNON: Like
AOL circa '96.
MIKE MACDONALD: Exactly.
Early days of AOL.
And I would say, is
this a funny idea?
Should this character take this
choice or take that choice?
Jilly would respond back,
how about neither choice?
What about this?
JILLY GAGNON: So we would
have these e-mail chains.
And the delay on
the e-mails could
be several minutes at a time.
It was like living in a horrible
world from 10 years ago.
And the vast majority of
the e-mails are like, nah.
That's not funny.
Nope.
That's not good.
Oh, that is pretty funny.
But like, no.
We're not doing it anyway.
So I would say while
Mike was in Tanzania,
the progress was fairly slow.
And then luckily he came back.
And we could do things on Skype.
And things could move
a little more quickly.
But we threw up here one of
the most difficult things
was the organizing of this.
MIKE MACDONALD: Yeah.
Before I got back to
Canada, in Tanzania,
we didn't have a
singular document
to store all this
information that you're
looking at right now.
So what I did was I
had Post-it notes.
And I would be posting
everything in my bedroom.
But the humidity is such that
they wouldn't actually stick.
So everything would
always fall to the ground.
So my roommates would
come in and they'd
see me frantically trying
to stick everything
back up to the wall, being
like, oh, it doesn't fit here.
It looked like a scene out of
"A Beautiful Mind," or something
like that.
But sure enough, Jilly
came up with this solution.
A piece of software
called Gliffy.
I'm not sure if you guys
are familiar with them.
I think it's used
primarily by engineers.
But we started to plot
everything down here.
JILLY GAGNON: Yeah.
I mean, basically
what had happened
is we had been doing
this back and forth.
And so choose your
adventure books,
you have different choices.
And for us, we would try to
go down different threads
one at a time.
This is where you start.
And we will say, we
went to the right.
So we're going to keep
going to the right
until we get to the
end of this storyline.
But it quickly became
really difficult to know
where we still had
like, open ends, where
we needed to go next.
You can see it's kind
of a complicated system
that we ended up with.
We wanted things to route
back into each other.
We wanted things
to-- there was just
all kind of things we were
hoping to do with this book
organizationally.
And it was not possible
to keep doing this
by emails and a document.
We were like, I
think this goes here.
So I searched for free
flow chart software.
And magically, one existed.
And it worked really well.
So this is probably the
ugliest-- it's probably
making engineers cringe.
It's just like boxes
and like blinds.
But it worked really well for us
to help organize our thoughts.
MIKE MACDONALD: If you just
look at the chart right now,
actually, the boxes kind of do
tell a story within themselves.
If you look at
all the red boxes,
those are boxes where in
the book you get fired,
or you're on worker's
comp or what have you.
JILLY GAGNON: Then,
your story ends.
MIKE MACDONALD: Yeah.
Exactly.
And then if you look
at the green boxes,
that's where you get rerouted
back to the beginning,
and you have to start again.
That's sort of Groundhog
Day, if you will.
This, of course, provided
a lot of headaches
in that consistency and
continuity were paramount
to this project, because if
you have something that happens
at the very top, you have to
make sure that you incorporate
that detail into
the very bottom,
regardless of all the other
previous choices you made.
Well, that's difficult. That
also proved very interesting
for writing jokes,
because we could also
incorporate a lot of meta-jokes
into the book by saying
basically regardless
of what you choose,
you're going to end
up in the same spot
at the end of the day.
JILLY GAGNON: Yeah.
And the other
interesting thing is
in a choose your
own adventure book,
I might always start by
going left or whatever.
So I think I've introduced
a character here.
Great.
We've all met Debbie.
You know, everyone knows Debbie.
We can move on.
Well, not true.
Not everybody chooses the way
I choose, believe it or not.
I'm always shocked by that fact.
But it's the truth.
So you have to find ways
to reintroduce scenarios
that doesn't seem
redundant, but does give you
enough information to grab onto,
because it's the same office,
no matter where you go.
It's the same coworkers.
It's the same meetings.
You know, all of that
stuff has to stay fixed.
Those are sort of
like Whovian things.
Those are fixed points in time.
And everything else we
can fudge around it.
So yeah.
We thought one of the
things that we really
enjoyed was the meta-joke of the
routing back to the beginning.
If you have had any-- I don't
know why you would have had
time in the last
five minutes to read
the first pages of our book--
but you start out hung over.
So at the end, we get you drunk.
And then it starts again.
Like, that is one of the
things that we think is--
MIKE MACDONALD: Exactly.
JILLY GAGNON: I don't know.
Probably we think it's funny.
MIKE MACDONALD:
It made us laugh.
Yeah.
Definitely.
JILLY GAGNON: So
that's all a long way
to say that we finally came up
with a behemoth that we could
call our own, and went
through the sort of-- I mean,
it's not particularly
interesting.
Standard process of finding
someone to put this book out
into the world.
And then as quickly
as we possibly could,
we quite our jobs.
You know, why not?
MIKE MACDONALD: Right.
So we could focus on
hopefully doing a few more
of these books.
JILLY GAGNON: Yeah.
There are a couple more coming.
MIKE MACDONALD: So that is it.
So the book is out-- I
guess the next slide-- Yeah.
JILLY GAGNON: You know.
That's it.
We know that the book exists.
MIKE MACDONALD:
The rest is gravy.
JILLY GAGNON: You pumped?
MIKE MACDONALD: Yeah.
JILLY GAGNON: We did as
well as in this photo.
So yeah.
At this point, we wanted to give
you a little taste of the book.
We wanted to do a short reading.
And I'm not sure-- I'm assuming
most people have heard of
or encountered a choose
your own adventure book.
But if you have not, the concept
of a choose your own adventure
book is essentially
like a non-linear book.
Even "Cloud Atlas."
Even crazy, everything is
happening at different times.
You turn from page 9
to 10, and then to 11.
And you read forward.
In a choose your own adventure
book, you read a chapter.
We call them nodes.
They're almost more like
moments than full chapters.
And at the end of
that moment, you're
presented with two choices.
And whichever thing you choose
is where you will go next.
Foregoing this other
mysterious option.
Or if you're like
me, you would cheat
and you would try to find out
all the options beforehand.
But much like life,
what you choose
affects the rest
of your experience.
So.
MIKE MACDONALD: Yeah.
With that being said,
with all these choices,
we're going to have to
put things to a vote
here for this
interactive reading.
So just for a little
warm up, can I
hear you guys clap and
sort of hoot and holler?
JILLY GAGNON: Yay!
MIKE MACDONALD: Great.
[INAUDIBLE]
So if I read out a choice,
and that's the choice
you want, if you could just
clap and hoot and holler.
And we'll sort of just
base it upon sound.
JILLY GAGNON: But Mike
will read both choices.
So you know what options
you actually have.
MIKE MACDONALD: Exactly.
So I'm going to take you to
the very beginning of the book.
And I'm sort of just going to
synthesize the very first node.
JILLY GAGNON: We want to
warm you up on the voting.
MIKE MACDONALD: Exactly.
So you wake up.
You're hung over.
Stage 5 hangover.
You're feeling quite terrible.
You think you're
in a pool of what
hopefully is your own urine.
You hear the alarm
clock blaring.
You have to get up.
It's time to go to work.
So you've got two options here.
The first option is you
can hit the alarm clock
and get a little more sleep.
Or the second option is,
you can just call in sick.
So if you want to
hit the alarm clock,
can you give a little clap?
JILLY GAGNON: The snooze button.
[CLAPPING]
MIKE MACDONALD: Great.
And if you want to
call in sick, clap.
[LOUDER CLAPPING]
JILLY GAGNON: All right.
So we're calling in sick--
MIKE MACDONALD: We're
calling in sick.
JILLY GAGNON: What I
think is happening.
So.
"In fact, going into work at
all today is not an option.
You fumble on your
nightstand for your phone.
No one should be in the
office for at least two hours.
You know it's a cop out.
And it'll probably make your
manager ask questions tomorrow.
But right now, the idea
of actually speaking
to a real person is impossible
to wrap your shattered
head around.
By tomorrow you'll have a
good enough answer for her.
You tap in the office number.
Hello?
Shit.
No one was supposed to answer.
Uh, who's this?
What do you want?
The fog of your brain
clears momentarily.
You recognize this
creaking, wavery voice.
It's Betsy, the ancient
receptionist who apparently
sleeps under her desk.
Sorry, I didn't expect anyone
would be in at this hour.
I was just calling because
I've been up all night sick.
And I really don't think--
You don't have any sick
days left, she says.
Well, just use one of
my vacation days then.
Please.
You've already used 9 out
of your 10 vacation days.
I understand that.
But I'm too ill.
And it's March."
MIKE MACDONALD: OK.
So from here we've
got two options.
The first option is that you
can use your last vacation day
and call in sick.
Or you could backtrack
and go into the office.
So if you guys want to use
your last vacation day,
let's hear a round of applause.
[WEAK CLAPPING]
MIKE MACDONALD: OK.
JILLY GAGNON: Going in.
Into the breach, I think.
MIKE MACDONALD: And if you want
to go back into the office,
little clap.
[LOUDER CLAPPING]
MIKE MACDONALD: All right.
JILLY GAGNON: All right.
"Yeah.
I really do need to save
that for-- you can't think
of any reason that
you'll actually
need the day, except a
hangover worse than this one,
which you can't actually
bear to imagine.
Later.
I'll be in soon.
You look over at the
clock and realize
that because of your
attempts to play hooky,
you're now running
seriously late.
There's no time for a shower.
You're just going to have
to use that Axe hanging out
of the back of the
bathroom medicine cabinet--
how do you even
inherit that-- and hope
that your sweat doesn't
smell too much like vodka.
You grab cleanish-looking
clothes off the floor
and put them on.
The can of Anarchy
for Him scented Axe,
and start spraying the entire
six-foot radius around you.
But nothing happens.
Even you can smell the clammy,
processed alcohol scent
creeping out of your pores.
[INAUDIBLE] later.
Frantic, you dig
through the cupboard
under the bathroom sink
for anything, something,
to cover the smell
of your shame.
You come up with a
mostly empty bottle
of your ex-roommate's perfume,
and a can of Glade air
freshener.
The air freshener somehow
seems like the better choice.
Your roommate was a hippie.
Spraying a massive cloud,
you twirl through it
and run out the door
to catch a cab."
MIKE MACDONALD: OK.
So this is one of these
situations where you actually
don't have a choice.
And we just route you
directly to another scenario.
JILLY GAGNON: Tough luck.
You made your decisions
already, people.
Now you're going.
You're going in the cab.
"You call the cab.
You anxiously pace the sidewalk
in front of your house.
Jesus.
The cab's never coming.
Maybe you should call
the dispatcher again?
Finally it arrives.
And it smells terrible.
Like shit that's
been cooked up in BO,
then been eaten, and
then shat out again.
You feel your stomach churn.
Cab driver speeds away from your
house, racing to the red light
at the end of the block, and
then abruptly hits the brakes.
The tires screech in protest.
Motherfucking idiot
drivers can't make it
through a single
cocksucking light,
he mutters under his breath.
This is really-- this is
a G-rated reading, guys.
Somehow it makes
the cab smell worse.
You feel your stomach
fly into your mouth.
The entire ride is agonizing,
filled with hard stops
and jumping starts.
Finally you arrive
outside your office.
You reach for your wallet.
The car jolts forward again.
Oh, Jesus.
Here it comes.
[RETCHING SOUND]
You've puked all
over your shoes.
You can't stop puking
all over your shoes.
You need to catch your breath.
Has anyone ever died from
hangover puking too much?
[RETCHING]
You think you can feel a blood
vessel in your eye burst.
A long string of saliva
dribbles down from your mouth
and hits your knees.
Get the fuck out, shit stain!
Driver screams.
You reach for your
wallet, hoping
to find a massive,
mysterious wad of cash.
Get the fuck out!
You run out of the cab, trying
to ignore the squelching
sound your shoes are
making, because it
might turn your stomach again.
You can wash your shoes
when you get upstairs.
It'll be fine.
Just get into the elevator and
just before the doors close,
the delicate hand
shoots between them.
Your crush Alex walks
into the elevator.
It's clear from the
affronted look on her face
that she has
smelled your shoes."
MIKE MACDONALD: OK.
So here you've got two options.
The first option is if you want
to blame the puke on somebody
else, you can turn to this node.
The other option is if you
want to pretend that nothing
has happened at all--
JILLY GAGNON: Normal.
Just Wednesday.
MIKE MACDONALD: You can do that.
So if you want to blame
the puke on somebody else,
round of applause.
[CLAPPING]
MIKE MACDONALD: And if you
just want to play it off
cool as though
nothing has happened.
[CLAPPING]
JILLY GAGNON: I don't know.
MIKE MACDONALD:
Maybe the second one.
JILLY GAGNON: All right.
Nothing's wrong here, guys.
We're good.
"By the time you
reach your floor,
both you and Alex are doing
your best not to gag audibly.
You'll just have to wait another
few weeks before you work up
the courage to ask her out.
It'll be fine.
This will be a funny story
you two share some day, right?
You head to the bathroom,
rinse out your shoes
with an expertise born
of tragic experience,
and head back to your desk.
Though you detest
almost everything
about your company
and your job, there's
something comforting
about your cubicle.
It's home to your
favorite break room mug,
your ergonomic computer wrist
supports, your trusty laptop,
which is where, exactly?
Well, shit.
It takes you all
of a millisecond
to realize you
forgot it at home.
You stare at your
empty desk mutely,
face contorted in horror.
It's even more galling since you
knew you weren't actually going
to really dig in on that
presentation you were supposed
to give today.
Have you ever once
worked from home?
But even if it's just a prop
on the conference room table,
you can't do the presentation
without the laptop.
It'll be too obvious
that you're bullshitting
when you don't have it there.
If memory serves--
debatable, considering
your current state-- the laptop
is on your kitchen table,
exactly where you left it when
you walked through the door
last night."
So I think this is
probably the last--
MIKE MACDONALD: Yeah.
This will be the last one
choice where we really want
to hear you guys clap here.
So if you want to go and grab
a loaner computer for the day,
that would be one option.
The other option is if you want
to go run and go home and grab
your computer from there.
So for the first
option, if you want
to grab the loaner computer,
can we hear a round of applause?
[APPLAUSE]
MIKE MACDONALD: Great.
And if you want to go home
and grab your proper computer,
let's hear a round of applause.
[WEAK CLAPPING]
MIKE MACDONALD: OK.
So loaner computer it is.
JILLY GAGNON: Loaner it is.
"You head to the IT department.
It's always the first
thing you notice
is the smell-- soup and
Breathe Right strips.
You try to breathe
through your mouth.
Any chance I can get
a loaner for the day,
you ask the nearest IT guy.
It's slim pickings.
We've got a Samsung.
But it doesn't
have Office on it,
he replies, never
taking his eyes
off the fanfic
site he's reading.
I kind of need Office.
I mean, doesn't every PC
ever made have Office?
No.
I also have a MacBook Air.
But a few of the keys
don't work, he says.
Which ones?
The E, Enter, numbers,
and the space bar.
All right.
Taking the Samsung.
The IT guy-- is it Brian?
Andy?
You should really know
his name by now-- reaches
for the Samsung.
Be careful not to unplug it.
It will instantly shut
off the power if the power
supply cuts out, he says.
There's nothing to say to
that, so you walk away.
You see your boss
walking down the hallway
in the opposite direction.
Looking forward to
that big presentation,
he says, as he passes you.
Get your hopes up, you
say with a forced laugh.
Hopefully it was
convincing enough
to mask your anxiety
and fear, seeing
as the presentation isn't
finished or even started."
MIKE MACDONALD: OK.
And I guess we'll leave
it there on a cliffhanger.
JILLY GAGNON: Yeah.
Oh!
You can only find out in
the actual office adventure
what might happen next.
MIKE MACDONALD: So I
think that's the talk.
JILLY GAGNON: Yeah.
And if people have-- this
is the question hour now.
So please, ask us anything.
Or just something.
It can be personal.
It can be about Mike's
renditions of "Oh Canada."
AUDIENCE: Thanks so much
for talking, and the book.
I'm really excited to read it.
JILLY GAGNON: Awesome!
Thank you so much for listening.
AUDIENCE: I have a kind
of a logistical question
about the creation of the book.
How did you decide where to
put the different sections?
Like where it says,
jump to page 6.
How did you decide to
put page 6 and not page
halfway through the book?
JILLY GAGNON: Well, that's
actually-- it's interesting.
So when we started,
we had that document.
And we were writing
them as separate nodes.
Everything we would
label on the flow chart.
So 1A, 2AB, 3ABCD, etc.
Going down.
And when we wrote it up,
we put those in order
and linked like a Word doc
hyperlink to go through it.
And then we gave
it to our printer
instead of our publishers.
And they magically made
that into real pages.
So the short answer to that
question is, I don't know.
We just put them in order,
and then hoped for the best.
They probably futzed
with it a little bit.
But the thing that happens with
those-- and you see it really
quickly once you start
going through them--
at the beginning
of the adventures,
they're all page 2 or 3, page
4 or 5, or the next options.
And then it starts
skipping quite a lot,
because there's just too
many other things in between
that you haven't chosen.
So it feels like a
mysterious experience,
hopefully, where you
don't know what's coming.
And I would encourage
you to occasionally
flip through the
book with no goal
whatsoever and see
what you can find.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So how do you
proofread a thing like this?
MIKE MACDONALD: So what we do
is we collaborate on the ideas.
And then we will go
our separate ways.
You know, I'll
write up my parts.
Jilly will write up her parts.
Then we'll meet again via Skype.
And we'll go over
each line, basically.
And we'll go over it.
Is this funny?
Is this pushing
the action forward?
So just like a line
by line edit, I guess.
JILLY GAGNON: But then
beyond that, once we
have the book in hand, and
you have it mostly set up,
it is extremely involved.
And we had to create multiple
versions of that chart
that we went through and
just changed everything
to blacked out everyone
that we've gone through.
So you have to start the
beginning every time,
and go through the entire way.
And then have to start
from the beginning
again, and go through, and
at the very last moment
turn right instead of left.
It is a long,
long, long process.
You inevitably miss things.
Our editor, Laura Duane
was phenomenal on that.
She went through
and she's like, I
don't think you introduced
Debbie in this thread.
We're like, nope.
We didn't.
And she caught a
lot of that for us.
But this will be like
a fun Easter egg,
like, find the mistakes, because
they're almost certainly still
in there.
It is really hard to make
sure that every single way you
do it, everything has been
introduced specifically
in that thread,
because someone will
go down that thread
very first and find out
that we didn't do it right.
So it was very, very long.
I used to proofread
professionally, though.
So I've got that good OCDI.
Hopefully we caught most of it.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering
if you could say anything
about writing as a
comedy partnership,
like any sort of ground
rules or secret to success,
or differences in
your sense of humor.
MIKE MACDONALD: Yeah.
Well, I think as I mentioned
before, you sort of don't
want to be precious
about your ideas.
You should be willing to just
discard an idea whenever.
I think the goal has always
been to create the strongest
piece of content.
So whether it be
writing headlines
for "The Smew" or "The Onion,"
or writing these videos,
we always just say, you know,
is this the funniest thing
that we can come up with?
If not, give me an alternative.
JILLY GAGNON: Yeah.
I think the very
first rule is that you
have to be willing to abandon
most of your own ideas.
Like, you have to assume
that your ideas are not
going to be the best that
anybody comes up with.
And you can't get
worked up about that.
It can't be personal.
Which is hard.
It was a little bit easier
to start with four people,
because out of four,
the chances are
good that yours isn't
everybody's favorite
every time.
But it doesn't feel as personal.
So by the time it
was just Mike and me,
we were really used to the
idea of me saying, like,
that's not funny.
And vice versa.
But yeah.
Generally what you
try to do-- we'll
will fight for ideas
that we want to keep,
and say, let me explain why
it is in fact really funny.
But if it's not
working, like Mike said,
the very first thing
you sort of say is, OK.
That's fine.
It's not funny.
It's not working.
What do you suggest instead?
And you just have to keep
throwing ideas against the wall
until something sounds
right to both of you.
And then maybe someone else
will tell you it's not funny.
And you have to can
it again start over.
MIKE MACDONALD: It helps a lot
in that we read our work out
to one another as
we edit and rewrite.
Because you can see on a
person's face via Skype,
or you'll get a laugh as to
whether or not this is funny.
When you're writing stuff
by yourself in a room,
you might think it's funny.
But if you don't have anybody
to bounce the ideas off,
you're a little bit uncertain.
I think broadly speaking, I
like my comedy sort of dry.
JILLY GAGNON: Yep.
MIKE MACDONALD: And Jilly
sort of likes her comedy
maybe a little more zany.
And we often meet in the middle.
So she's got this X voice.
I've got this Y voice.
And when we put it together,
you create this sort of Z voice.
JILLY GAGNON: Zed.
Oh my gosh.
You're so Canadian.
Yeah.
We hear it as zed voice.
But yeah.
Reading out I think is
the other secret trick.
They tell all
authors to do that.
And that you feel ridiculous.
And you don't read your
work in front of a mirror.
But it's amazing what you hear
that you wouldn't feel when
you're reading it in your head.
And the rhythm of comedy
makes a huge difference.
A joke can land or fail just
based on like, one extra word.
And when you're
reading it out, you
can suddenly hear like, oh,
I went on way too long here.
Like, gone.
So I hope that
answered your question.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
I have a son in college,
a freshman in college
who has been writing to
their satirical paper.
So I was wondering,
how do you land
an internship at
"The Onion," and what
that experience was like.
MIKE MACDONALD: Sure.
JILLY GAGNON: I wouldn't know.
MIKE MACDONALD: I
did a Master's degree
over at the London
School of Economics.
And I chose to write
my dissertation
on the political relevance
of satirical news.
So in doing that process,
I contacted people who
at Colbert, Jon Stewart.
This hour has 22 minutes,
for the [INAUDIBLE]
in the audience.
As well as "The Onion."
And "The Onion" were
enthused with the project.
Once I got my research and
done all the interviews,
I went back to them.
And I said, you
know, I'm not sure.
But I've got some jokes.
Would you be willing
to read them?
And that sort of progressed
into a conversation
about doing an internship
in New York, which was
six months at the time, unpaid.
I jumped on it.
I thought that it
was a great offer.
And then I suppose
toward the end of that,
they had a bunch of interns.
There's a sort of competition
for a few writing slots.
And you submit jokes.
Each week, I think, you submit
something like 15 jokes.
And from there they'll
pick one or two people.
And I was fortunate enough to
get a contributing position,
which I had for two years.
And then they let me go.
And then they rehired me again.
And I brought Jilly
on board, of course.
But I would say, just reach out.
If you want to talk to somebody
about the potential of getting
a job, I think interviewing
that person beforehand
is a great way to go about it.
JILLY GAGNON: It's
like a sneak attack.
MIKE MACDONALD: Exactly.
JILLY GAGNON: Interview
them about what they do.
Although the other thing
that is probably useful
if your son-- you said
your son-- is a freshman,
keep doing it for a
couple years before you're
going after that slot, because
he's gonna get so much better.
Your jokes are going to get so
much better the more you do.
And they might not
think you're ready now.
But two years from now, when
you've done this for that
much longer, and you've had
these conversations we have
with each other about
this wasn't working
and this is why, what
you submit to them
is going to be so much stronger.
And you will have
probably a better
shot of getting your
foot in the door.
MIKE MACDONALD: Yeah, of course.
JILLY GAGNON: But
like, try everything.
Go to the internet
for random websites.
Do everything.
And then you'll get better.
MIKE MACDONALD: Great.
Perfect.
AUDIENCE: So first, thanks
for talking to us today.
It seems you've
chosen to continue
to work in the choose
your own adventure form.
I'm actually curious why you
decided to do more of it.
It's not that it's bad, it's
just that it could have been,
that was a great, funny idea.
Now let's do something else.
JILLY GAGNON: Well, we are
in a very fortunate position,
actually.
We wrote this book.
And we had the idea.
And we had it all done up.
And when our agent told
us that she had sold it,
she said, and they
want a three-book deal.
And that is manna from heaven.
So we said, that's awesome.
And we always had tons of ideas.
We always saw that
there could be
a ton of-- there's a lot of
misery that you can hit on.
The holidays for us was
such an obvious next choice.
So when they said
that, we said, perfect.
We know what we will do next.
And we were hoping--
still are hoping--
that that will help us get
a little bit established
so that the next
time we do a project,
people have heard of us,
and they're excited for it.
MIKE MACDONALD: Yeah, exactly.
I think we always thought
from early days, OK,
we could transpose this
format onto another subject.
There's a ton of
fodder out there.
We thought of Choose
Your Own Misery:
The Maternity Leave,
Choose Your Own Misery:
The Online Dating Adventure.
And so the idea is that
we can sort of put this on
are almost endless.
JILLY GAGNON: Yeah.
Now we've figured
out how to do it.
And we'll have one
more crack at it.
We've already written
the holiday book.
So hopefully we'll
get better and better.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Well, good luck.
MIKE MACDONALD:
Thank you so much.
AUDIENCE: I was just
wondering if you guys could
talk a little bit more
about-- you mentioned
that you work together, right?
Most of this is
over the internet.
MIKE MACDONALD: Right.
AUDIENCE: So just how you think
that both benefited or made
it more difficult to write,
and kind of your experience
with the digital relationship.
JILLY GAGNON: A completely
digital relationship.
It's so funny,
because Mike and I,
this is probably
like the fourth time
we've hung out in
person, fifth time.
Like, everything was
done over the internet.
One thing I would
say, I think having
most of our conversations
through Skype
as opposed to in person, it
is a little bit of a barrier.
So when you talk
about like that being
able to give up
your ego with jokes
and give up your
work really easily,
I think maybe it's not
something I would consciously
have said before.
But maybe that made
it a bit easier
to let go of stuff, because
you're still in your own space.
Your space is still yours.
And there's that little bit
of a barrier between you
that makes it slightly
less difficult to say, OK.
Fine.
We'll move on.
We'll do the next thing.
MIKE MACDONALD: Yeah.
When we started writing scripts,
there's a few more people
that were writing with us.
And we actually used Google
Hangouts for the most part.
And that was always great.
JILLY GAGNON: Thank you.
MIKE MACDONALD: Yeah, exactly.
JILLY GAGNON: You
guys, seriously,
like, we kind of exist
because of Google.
So, thanks.
MIKE MACDONALD: Yeah.
The idea that you can sort
of teleconference with four
or five people.
And whoever is sort of talking
the loudest would be the most
prominent in the screen
was such a great idea
for this collaborative process.
JILLY GAGNON: And it got
us all to talk louder,
which was fantastic too.
MIKE MACDONALD: But yeah.
No.
I agree with Jilly.
It does sort of create this
barrier that you can pause.
And you can do your own thing.
You can make a cup of
coffee without having
to worry about entertaining
the person in the room,
and then jump back on the
call and get through it again.
JILLY GAGNON: Yeah.
Or you can duck out and weep.
And then you're
like, no, I'm cool.
Let's keep moving.
It's normal stuff like that.
AUDIENCE: Did you ever have a
situation where you're alone.
You're doing your
thing, getting ready.
And you just, this is so
funny, you're laughing,
you can't stop.
You know, water's coming out
your nose, the whole thing.
You know.
And then you share it
with your next Skype.
And they're like, no.
That's not funny.
How do you deal with
that kind of thing?
You know it's really funny.
JILLY GAGNON: Duck out of frame.
You weep.
And then-- And yes, absolutely.
I think we probably both
had stuff where you're like,
this is so it.
This is the thing
that is going to make
every joke come together.
And the other person is
like, I'm not feeling that.
Like, I don't see where
you're going with this.
MIKE MACDONALD: Yeah.
I think we've been working
together long enough that we
really trust each other.
And if Jilly finds
something really funny,
I'll trust that the
joke is funny as well.
Maybe I'll try to add or
augment it here or there so
that we can sort of
shape it up a little bit.
But if she comes
to me and is very
enthusiastic about an
idea, more times than not,
we'll run with it.
And vice versa.
JILLY GAGNON: Right.
And I think the other
thing we will sometimes do
is-- I think I said before.
We had a joke that we were
like water out the nose into.
You fight for it.
If the other person is
like, I don't get it,
you try to explain yourself,
you try to fight for it.
And one of the things we
we'll sometimes do is say,
can we leave it in place for now
and come back to it tomorrow.
And see if you've processed
it, so that the person who
maybe brought it in can feel
a little bit less close to it.
And the person who
didn't bring it in
can turn it over in
their head and see
if they feel the same way.
So that has helped the ability
to turn off the computer
screen, vent to your
significant other or my cats,
and come back later makes it a
little bit easier to do that.
But sometimes you just have to
let go of things that you love
that you thought were great.
And maybe they
weren't great for what
we were doing together now.
So.
We're like very Zen.
We've learned how to
get rid of all ego.
AUDIENCE: Since no
one else is asking,
I'll ask another question.
Do you think of humor as there
being like genres of humor?
Like, for example,
I have friends
who won't watch "Curb Your
Enthusiasm" because it's
cringe humor.
And it's just too painful
for them to watch.
And others just can't
get enough of it.
And you know, there's
the stand up stuff.
And then "Onion" kind
of humor and stuff.
And if so, where do
you see yourselves?
JILLY GAGNON: Well,
we're definitely
in the dark humor spectrum.
Definitely towards that end
where I think both of us
see humor as a
really important way
to deal with difficult things.
It's like a catharsis, the
catharsis element of humor,
which sort of pushes you
towards darker topics a lot
of the time.
If you can't laugh about it,
you'll cry about it topics.
So we're definitely
on the dark side.
I think we're definitely
on the dry side.
It's a bit of a British
vibe, sometimes.
MIKE MACDONALD: I think so.
That's what people on
Amazon have been saying.
JILLY GAGNON: Yeah.
They're like, these Brits.
I'm like, that's not.
We're actually I think shelved--
or like one of the drop downs
on Amazon is British humor.
I'm like, great.
That's fantastic.
MIKE MACDONALD:
British and Irish.
JILLY GAGNON: Yeah.
British and Irish humor.
So now you know.
AUDIENCE: Which
really pisses you off.
JILLY GAGNON:
Yeah, he's annoyed.
I'm like, awesome.
They have such great accents.
But yeah.
I'd say we're dry.
We definitely
also-- I think we've
both said this before-- it
works better as written humor.
A lot of it, seeing it
and thinking it over,
and some of that like subtle
wit or wryness or whatever,
is easier in that form.
And perhaps maybe we're just not
good enough performers for it.
But that kind of humor, I
think, plays better on the page
than it maybe does in person.
Whereas a little bit
more over-the-topness
in stand-up humor, no matter how
dark it is, works better there.
So probably wry, a little bit
understated, and very dark.
AUDIENCE: And just
in the few pages
you read, I didn't hear a lot
of Dilbert in your office humor.
JILLY GAGNON: I hope that's
not a disappointment.
AUDIENCE: You've delved
into some video before.
And I was wondering if there are
any moments in your video chats
that you think might make
a good thing to share
with the internet.
JILLY GAGNON: Yeah.
I mean--
MIKE MACDONALD: Well, lately
what we've been doing,
I have a Skype recorder.
So when we do our
Skype sessions,
I'll record the entire thing.
And then I'll go back
and skim over it.
And my face is in
the corner here.
And Julie's face is
the predominant one.
So I'll look.
And every time that she's
laughing, I'll stop the frame
and see what we're
talking about.
And then I'll cut
that in I guess
iMovie or something like that.
And then I'll export
the MP4 into Facebook.
Right now Facebook
seems like they're
pretty crazy on getting
sort of raw video uploaded.
So I'll upload that onto
Facebook, put that on our page.
And then we've got
a YouTube channel.
A Choose Your Own
Misery YouTube channel.
AUDIENCE: Whew!
JILLY GAGNON: Heck, yeah.
MIKE MACDONALD: Yeah.
And we'll put that
on there as well,
and tweet it out and put
it on our Google+ profile.
JILLY GAGNON: And
right now it's mostly
like that sort of
behind-the-scenes moments,
because when we're talking,
we crack each other up a lot.
Sometimes it's not
something that we
feel comfortable sharing
with the internet at large.
Like what's making
us laugh so hard.
But often it is.
And so we'll take those
little 15-second moments.
And that is our YouTube channel
at the moment is a lot of us.
And then a couple
videos that were
us doing very erudite readings
that we put up there as
well for people.
So not a lot of views yet.
Please, by all means, bump
up those views on the YouTube
channel.
AUDIENCE: I'll just say April
1st is a few months away.
And you could always
script one, too.
JILLY GAGNON: You're right.
You have a very good point.
Thanks for having us.
It was great.
MIKE MACDONALD: Yeah.
Thanks so much.
[APPLAUSE]